Et qu'en est-il des compagnies pétrolières, gazières et minières ?
Ok, peut-être que ça fait un peu cliché de parler d'elles.
De la corruption dans ce secteur n'est pas une surprise.
Il y a de la corruption partout, alors pourquoi se focaliser sur ce secteur?
Eh bien parce qu'il y a beaucoup en jeu.
En 2011, les exportations de ressources naturelles
ont dépassé les flux d'aide d'un facteur 19,
en Afrique, Asie et Amérique Latine. 19 !
Ça représente un sacré paquets d'écoles, d'universités,
d'hôpitaux, de startups, dont beaucoup
ne se sont pas matérialisés et ne le seront jamais
parce qu'une partie de cet argent a tout simplement été volée.
À présent retournons aux compagnies pétrolières et minières,
revenons à Dan Etete et à son contrat à 1 milliard de dollars.
Et pardonnez-moi, mais je vais vous lire la suite
parce que c'est vraiment un sujet brûlant, et nos avocats
l'ont revu dans le détail
et veulent que je m'exprime correctement.
A première vue, l'accord semble être honnête.
Les filiales de Shell et Eni
ont payé le gouvernement nigérian pour la concession.
Le gouvernement nigérian a transféré
précisément le même montant, au dollar près,
sur un compte assigné à une société écran
dont le détenteur caché était Etete.
Ce n'est pas une mauvaise affaire pour un homme reconnu coupable de blanchiment d'argent.
Mais il y a un truc.
Après plusieurs mois de recherche
et la lecture de centaines de pages de documents juridiques,
nous avons trouvé la preuve qu'en fait,
Shell et Eni ont appris que les fonds
seraient transférés à cette société écran,
et il est franchement dur de croire qu'ils ne savaient pas
à qui ils avaient à faire.
Ceci dit, ça ne devrait pas nécessiter autant d'effort
de découvrir où va l'argent de ce type de contrat.
Je veux dire, ce sont des biens nationaux.
Ils sont supposés bénéficier
à la population de ce pays.
Mais dans certains pays, citoyens et journalistes
essayant d'exposer ce genre d'histoires
ont été harcelés et arrêtés
et certains y ont même risqué leur vie.
Et pour finir, il y a ceux qui croient
que la corruption est inévitable.
C'est juste la façon dont on fait certaines affaires.
C'est trop complexe et difficile à changer.
Alors quoi ? Nous laissons faire.
Mais en tant que militante et enquêtrice,
j'ai un point de vue différent,
car j'ai vu ce qu'il peut se produire
quand une idée gagne du terrain.
Dans les secteurs pétrolier et minier, par exemple,
c'est à présent le commencement
d'un véritable standard de transparence au niveau mondial
qui pourrait permettre d'affronter certains de ces problèmes.
En 1999, quand Global Witness lança un appel
aux compagnies pétrolières afin qu'elles rendent les paiements de ce ce type de contrat transparents,
certaines personnes ont ri face à la naïveté
de cette petite idée.
Mais des centaines de groupes de la société civile
de par le monde se sont rassemblés
pour combattre l'opacité,
et à présent ça devient rapidement la norme et la loi.
2/3 de la valeur
des compagnies pétrolières et miniéres
sont à présent sous le coup des lois sur la transparence. 2/3 !
Alors le changement est en train de se produire.
Il y a du progrès.
Mais nous sommes encore très loin du compte.
Parce que le vrai problème, ce n'est pas la corruption
ici ou là-bas, n'est-ce pas?
À l'ère de la mondialisation, la corruption
est un business globalisé,
qui nécessite des solutions à l'échelle globale,
supportées et poussées par nous autres, citoyens du monde,
ici.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)